there are two research projects that I'm
working on currently which I think are
intriguing and important one of them is
looking at the nature of trying to make
a cohesive citizenship out of diversity
and understanding more some of the
cultural concerns related to that
project and I'm interested both in the
majority native-born population that for
very understandable reasons feels that
their society is changing quite quickly
when you have when you have newcomers
coming from very diverse religious or
ethnic or racial backgrounds and
different cultures and so I'm very
interested in knowing how can you help
create sort of cross group dialogues and
a an easier process of integration for
both of those groups and then also on
the immigrant side how do immigrants and
how can they reimagine their position in
a society where the modal person of that
society might not be someone who looks
like themselves so someone who might be
of a religious minority background but
it's perceived that someone who is
American or Canadian has to be Christian
and so how do you reimagine the national
identity your nationality in a way that
becomes inclusive so there's that
project another project that I'm very
interested in which builds on some of my
previous research is that I think that
civil society and how robust civil
society is for immigrant communities is
fundamental for them to get to make
advances in all kinds of areas so not
just becoming a citizen but helping
people to get into the labor market
helping people who maybe are facing you
know social isolation seniors who might
not have a lot of support networks and
so community-based organizations do a
lot of fundamental work on that and one
of the questions I'm asking in the
American context right now is whether
the incidence of community-based
organization the nonprofit organizations
that do so much important work in our
communities whether they are really
targeting immigrant issues and immigrant
populations to the same extent that we
find immigrants in the general
population our research seems to be
suggesting that the number
of community-based organizations that
deal with immigrant issues is only half
as much as what we would expect given
the immigrants in the population and
this really raises huge questions about
civics civic stratification so
inequality in our community-based
organizations and inequality in the
civil society that sort of helps us get
things done and I'm interested in
knowing why